[Music]
this week of Amyas Walters more of a
romantic love story you guys promise
romance and you you gave us some romance
we deliver and there was like I don't
know how to define it but a subtle
difference between the sexy and the
romance that was really kind of sweet
well I mean this song itself says
something's are very different to our
week one day and some Viennese Waltz
requires something a little softer and
we worked on it a lot we worked on the
intention and how to move as one with
each other
[Applause]
yeah it was easier for me to connect to
and my uncle suffered from a bad horse
wreck last year and unfortunately his
walk away wasn't the same as mine and he
wound up in a wheelchair so I knew I was
just visualizing him being able to dance
with my aunt and slow slow dance so that
kind of connected me and you got some
tears from your family as you were
talking about that you may not have
known that that was pretty touchy yeah
they didn't know I was gonna say any of
that and it meant a lot for that side of
the family to be here so
[Music]